[Music]
when I was in elementary school I would
always talk about how one day I wanted
to be a Lego master model builder and my
parents were like that's cute Robby you
should go to school and you should go to
college and get good grades and be
responsible at adult and here I am being
a responsible adult but still getting to
fill my childhood passion of playing
with Lego bricks so we're here inside
the model shop we have a collection of
more than three million Lego bricks we
have some really rare colors here like
plated gold or Lego actually made gold
bricks all in all we have more than 70
colors to work with here in the model
shop you know the ideas start in
someone's imagination and may get it
down however they can whether they use a
computer or a pencil and paper so right
now I'm working with the model shop
special proprietary computer drawing
software it's just like any kind of CAD
program that you'd use in an
architecture firm or at an art studio
except ours is based in LEGO bricks it
allows us to build 3d with bricks and
you can get way up close and you can see
on the inside where all the bricks would
be you can also zoom out and get a great
overview of your model here we have one
of the guardian dragons from lego
ninjago world we installed one of these
this morning but this just gives you a
feel for what the model is going to look
like so when it comes time to build the
Lego model using what we've done here on
the computer we'll take this screen and
it shows the model in slices and it
shows a slice for every Lego layer of
plate and then what we'll do is we'll
scroll up one layer at a time and every
time we scroll up one layer will build
those Lego bricks and those Lego plates
The Guardian dragon will install this
morning we estimate it has about 77280
bricks you know in the model shop we
work as teams so it would take one
person nearly a month to build that
dragon we're all master model builders
but each of us has strengths we can all
do everything but some of us do certain
things better than others Robbie's
really great at at replicating buildings
I'm kind of the greevil and snot guy and
snot stands for studs not on top when
you build stud sideways so whenever
there's a mosaic that's got some crazy
lines and stuff in it they always give
it to me well right now we're redoing
the New York area and I've built two
subway stations so this station is
modeled after after one that has a very
intricate mosaic well they had ended up
doing was jumping a reading plate a half
a step so you've got this really very
tight integrated mosaic it's not very
commonly done there's a big sense of
relief when you see kids and guests and
families enjoying everything that we've
so hard to build it's one thing because
we want to inspire our kids when we're
building our models but it's another to
see it happen to see a kids eyes light
up when he gets to look at one of those
dragons and say I could totally build
that at home and he could
[Applause]